ya hemos calculado la derivada parcial
de esta función vectorial y la pregunta
que quedaba era qué significa en una
digamos en un sentido geométrico verdad
y todo lo que tenemos que hacer es
visualizar esta función y con esta
función específica tenemos una entrada
bidimensional y la salida es
tridimensional lo que significa que la
salida tiene más dimensiones que la
entrada así que es bueno tratar de
visualizar esta superficie parametrizar
ahí la la forma que vamos a hacerlo
quizás podrías decir que es visualizar
la transformación verdad es pensar en el
plano ts verdad y aquí es en donde
tenemos todas las entradas y podríamos
pensar cómo es que se mapean digamos al
espacio tridimensional pero cuando
hacemos esto de hecho estamos haciendo
un poquito de trampa vamos a hacer un
poquito de trampa en vez de tener un
plano separado pongamos aquí el plano ts
así que vamos a ponerlo aquí y aquí en
realidad estamos recortando solo a
valores que van desde cero
para la variable t así que podríamos
pensar que cada una de estas marquitas
corresponde a un medio verdad así que
aquí está el 1 aquí está el 2 luego el 3
y lo mismo tenemos con la variable s así
que ese también va desde 0 a 3 y la
razón por la cual estoy poniendo esto en
el espacio tridimensional digamos
estamos sobreponiendo sobre el plano xy
verdad es simplemente para hacer la
animación un poquito más fácil porque
entonces el beneficio aquí es que
podríamos fijarnos en cada punto verdad
en cada uno de estos puntos así que si
pensamos digamos en alguna pareja ts
como una pareja de entrada verdad
entonces vamos a ver hacia dónde se va a
mover en la salida muy bien entonces la
salida es tridimensional sin embargo que
queremos verlo como una animación así
que aquí tenemos nuestro plano ts pero
dado nuestro cuadrado veamos con que
terminamos en una digamos en una
superficie verdad vamos a terminar con
una superficie y sólo para hacer esto un
poquito más más concreto
verdad vamos a irnos hacia acá y vamos a
fijarnos sólo en un punto
digamos no solo para poder visualizar la
función sino también para poder checar
cómo son las derivadas parciales muy
bien entonces el punto que vamos a
considerar es el punto 1,1 que estoy
pintando justo aquí así que tenemos la
pareja ts donde cada uno de estos vale
una verdad este es el 11 y podríamos
empezar a predecir digamos dónde va a
estar nuestra salida y para hacer esto
simplemente tenemos que introducir estos
valores en la función así que este es el
tipo de visualización que vamos a estar
checando vamos a introducir esto en
nuestra función así que tendremos 1 al
cuadrado menos 1 al cuadrado que es 0 1
por 1 verdad que eso nos da 1 y luego
tenemos uno por uno al cuadrado que es
uno menos uno por uno al cuadrado que
también es uno y nos da en total cero lo
cual nos dice que a esta entrada le
corresponde el vector de salida 0 1 0
verdad es un vector unitario que apunta
en la dirección y así que aquí estará él
de verdad podríamos pensar que es un
vector que se ve más o menos así es
unitario y que apunta en la dirección de
verdad ahora el punto en la superficie
vamos a ver al que corresponde verdad es
la punta de este vector
es la forma en que visualizamos cosas
parametrizados es justamente la punta
del vector el punto que estaremos
pensando verdad y si ponemos nuevamente
la animación el punto corresponde al 11
y en efecto termina en la punta del
vector así que al menos para este valor
podemos ver que no te estoy mintiendo
con la animación verdad y en principio
podríamos hacerlo para cualquier punto
dado cualquier punto de entrada
podríamos digamos introducirlo en la
función y dibujar el vector en el
espacio de tres dimensiones y ver la
animación verdad y ver dónde cae la
punta del vector ahora lo que queremos
empezar a pensar es que qué significa la
derivada parcial y recordemos este dt
verdad este pequeño dt nos dice que es
un pequeño empujoncito en la dirección
de t así que hacemos un pequeño
movimiento verdad
es un pequeño movimiento en la dirección
de t aquí es aquí está nuestro plano ts
verdad aquí está la dirección de t
entonces estamos moviéndonos en esta
dirección que se ve justamente con la
línea verdad que esto representa un
valor constante de s aquí en este caso s
sería igual a 1 en toda esa línea verdad
y por el contrario dejamos de correr
libremente y si vemos cómo se transforma
esta línea verdad bajo el mapeo a la
superficie parametrizado podemos tener
una idea de cómo está variando la
entrada con la entrada de verdad en el
espacio de salidas así que toda esta
línea rosa básicamente nos dice qué pasa
si a ese se mantiene constante que es
igual a 1 y dejamos hacer correr
libremente y obtenemos una curva en el
espacio de tres dimensiones verdad ahora
si tuviéramos otra constante s
tendríamos otra curva y quizás podríamos
ver aquí en digamos en las líneas de la
malla que tenemos pintada verdad qué
tipo de curvas podríamos tener así que
en lugar de pensar ahora en el
movimiento de t como como un todo verdad
pensemos ahora en pequeños empujones
ok pensemos ahora en en esto que hemos
denotado como parcial de verdad es algo
que estamos imaginando cómo un pequeño
un pequeño movimiento en la dirección de
verdad en realidad vamos lo estamos
pensando muy pequeño porque vamos a
tomar un límite eventualmente verdad si
queremos ser un poquito más precisos así
que digamos que parcial del tc algo como
0.01 verdad que es algo muy pequeño
verdad y si ahora nos fijamos en la
transformación en cómo se mueve ese
pequeño empujoncito entonces eso quizá
se estire o se encoja verdad pero va a
terminar resultando en una especie de
vector que apunta a lo largo de la curva
y por supuesto será tangente de esa
curva ese vector nos dice cómo nos
movemos digamos en una forma muy pequeña
muy pequeña pero tangente verdad así que
lo que estamos pensando es en un pequeño
cambio en el vector de salida de su es
parcial debe muy bien parecía el bebé y
entonces lo dividimos entre el pequeño
valor
o del tate de verdad que era de 0.01 y
entonces debido a que estamos dividiendo
entre algo muy pequeño nuestro vector va
a ser más grande así que la derivada
real va no va a ser algo muy muy pequeño
en realidad va a ser algo visible verdad
sólo que estamos escalando ese pequeño
vector que hemos obtenido verdad
apropiadamente en este caso sería
dividido entre una centésima o lo que es
lo mismo x si en verdad entonces eso es
lo que nos da un vector tangente a esta
curva y mientras más grande sea digamos
mientras más largo nos estará diciendo
que al variar t nos movemos digamos a lo
largo de esta curva rosa verdad en
movimientos mucho más rápidos y largos
la proporción de estos pequeños cambios
entonces sería más grande así que si
cambiamos un poquito la perspectiva
podríamos tener una mejor idea de cómo
se comporta la curva cerca de ese punto
y podemos ver que se mueve de forma
positiva en la dirección x verdad
también se mueve de forma positiva en la
dirección
y en la dirección zeta de hecho es
negativa verdad esta curva como que
tiende a irse hacia abajo en la variable
zetas y que antes de si quiere
introducir nuestros valores en la
función de la derivada parcial que
calculamos anteriormente podríamos decir
simplemente viendo la imagen que en el
valor x verdad va va a tender a irse
algo positivo en el valor que también
tendrá que irse algo positivo pero en la
dirección zeta se irá a algo negativo
verdad un poquito más negativo
simplemente de cómo se ve esta curva y
al menos eso es intuitivo así que vamos
a tratar de introducir estos valores
ahora en nuestra derivada parcial que ya
tenemos verdad así que cuando tenemos de
igual a uno bueno vamos a borrar esto
primero cuando tenemos que igual a 1
aquí tendremos 2 cuando ese es uno
tendremos uno y aquí tendremos uno al
cuadrado menos dos por uno por uno eso
es uno menos dos que es menos uno así
que recuperamos ese patrón de positivo
positivo negativo que habíamos visto y
también podríamos ver cómo es que en la
dirección x se mueve el doble de rápido
que en la dirección
de verdad se mueve más a la derecha que
en la dirección de jay otra vez en
principio podríamos imaginarnos hacer
esto no solo en un punto sino en
cualquiera verdad a lo largo de esta
curva o incluso a lo largo de toda la
superficie y el movimiento
correspondiente digamos la dirección en
la que nos está empujando la dirección
de verdad nos dará un vector en tres
dimensiones y esa es la interpretación
que tenemos de la derivada parcial de
funciones vectoriales y otra vez el
vector derivada no es el vector que
resulta del empujoncito con desde verdad
todavía falta dividir entre dt y bueno
formalmente tendríamos que hacer un
límite verdad ahora bien en el próximo
vídeo quiero tratar de hacer exactamente
lo mismo para ver qué pasa cuando
empujamos ahora en la dirección s sólo
para tener una buena idea de qué ocurre
en este ejemplo